und wenn ihr im zielraum modus die jetzt
verteilt und keine kassiert dann ist
eigentlich ziemlich safe dass ihr die
sache für euch entscheidet
servus es geht und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren kit vorstellung
gestellt er richtig viel spaß mit den
kipper stelle zu haben deswegen kommt
natürlich die nächste wird seinen weg
gehen einfach mal hier so eine kleine
runde rainer fich bio hat lust auf
planes ich mag planes eigentlich und wir
schauen wir mit golf spielen wir spielen
heute den die ihr das den ziel suche der
ziel sucher bekommt sobald sich ein
spieler mit weniger als 50 prozent leben
wenn einem radius von 50 plätzen
befindet spiel drei und plus zwei
schaden den er austeilt oder ein steckt
das heißt erst mal einiges viele
informationen an allererster stelle
natürlich der effekt tritt nur einen
wenn sich ein gegner mit weniger als der
hälfte seiner leben im umkreis von 50
blöcken um euch befindet und dann kriegt
ihr speed 30 und richtig schnell rennen
und dem sozusagen hinterher hetzen plus
ihr macht extrem viel schaden kriegt
aber auch extrem viel schreiben dass
alles in allem ziemlich cooles kipp wir
grüßen mal kurz die leute weil
einerseits erfahrt ihr natürlich wie
viel leben der gegner hat also erfahrung
hat jetzt weniger oder mehr als die
hälfte seiner leben weil sobald die
diesen speed effekt kriegt wisst ihr ja
ok der gegner ist geschwächt da kann ich
jetzt mal drauf gehen die sache ist die
so lange den wenigsten speed effekt hat
dann können auch nur die wenigsten
becker selbst hilfe kängurus ist das
nicht so leicht da wegzukommen usb3
einfach schon eine menge holz ist und
für seinen legen einfach mal los und
schauen muss die runde so ergibt gott
was für ein erbärmlicher anfangs küste
genommen
die reisen genommen nichts sei so schwer
der startet übrigens wieder hier unten
seht auf zwei und drei mit einem paar
gold schuhen ob sie da gibt's aus begabt
ein paar gold schuhen und einem gold
schwert wobei natürlich
na ja also es ist klar dass man im gold
schweiz jetzt nicht unbedingt so eine
runde gewinnen kann
falls doch schaut man die kommentare ob
er jemals im gold wert die runde
gemeistert habt ich halte das für eher
für unwahrscheinlich deswegen naja
dieses gold wert ist eher eine notlösung
würdig sein
ihr braucht auf jeden fall ein besseres
schwert mindestens eisen besser
natürlich dir oder sogar verzaubertes
die erschwert da was reißen zu können
stichwort reißen wir brauchen dringend
eine kiste wird bisschen mehr equipment
sonst müssen wir wirklich mal mit dem
gold wert in den einsatz gehen mit dem
goldstadt bisschen kämpfen
ich sehe mich wirklich einfach keine
kiste gerade noch 50 sekunden geht es
los das heißt es läuft auf gold wert
hinaus leute aber gut dann mit dem gold
wert wenn es so sein soll
sein handy ist nicht im flugmodus ein
bisschen raus hier aufgehört habt oder
störsignal tut mir sehr leid
der ist relativ gut klappt was machen
wir da ja zweimal da jetzt können
natürlich ein paar pfeile auf den
schmeißen die mhh nicht wirklich treffen
aber ich sitze die frage können wir uns
jemals stellen ein problem dar
orientiert sich damit bietet können
spielt effekt und zack da haben denn
down und das war richtig richtig knapp
da kommt der nächste wo gott oh gott der
hat die schuhe von delphin hoffentlich
kann er erstens nicht hinterherkommt und
ist nicht schnell genug oder jason sales
on stage ist und der andere wurde bei
switch der andere jacksons auch direkt
fakt was machen wir jetzt aus machen
jetzt auch nachher zu müssen dringend
unsere unsere testet anziehen ich hoffe
wir stellen jetzt nicht ziemlich gut
gesehen wie der besucher aus teilt okay
wenn man zumindest mal ein schwert
leider aber kein food da wenn wir sagen
immer dieses schwein du dummes nein du
bist keine dumme sau du bist einfach nur
ein kleines schweinchen was jetzt
sterben hasst er mit dem vermieter mit
gib mir dann mit
oder hält das loch ein schwein die
senior bisschen komisch aus dem text to
back bitte nicht auf mich danke ok
nämlich mit und dann reden wir jetzt wir
könnten aber mal hinterher laufen und
dann hoffentlich mal veranschaulichen
wie das so ist wenn dieser speed effekt
einsetzt weil denn dann merkt er halt
sofort sagt da ist einer der hat weniger
als die hälfte seiner leben und dann
wisst ihr halt okay jetzt muss ich ran
und jetzt kann ich auch ran weil der hat
wirklich wenig gegeben hat life ist
sozusagen
und es ist alles ziemlich coole man
fühlt sich der wenn ich jetzt mal so
pathetisch sprechen da fast wie so wie
so ein raubtier das jetzt in seinem
seinen film ist wenn sich alles
ausgeschaltet und dann auf jagd geht das
alles ziemlich ziemlich cool muss ich
sagen aber jetzt noch eine kiste die ist
leider dies kommt das war nix aber auch
keinen hut mehr
dann fehlt einfach so schnell hunger das
fest ein bisschen leider aber da kann
man nichts verändern müssen jetzt
bisschen bogen bekämpfen wir können
leider kann team machen kollege ich
hoffe ich ein paar pfeile habe ich nicht
egal aber auch so der ist noch nicht
live wir sind aber live das heißt wir
was man lieber die finger von dem sei
denn wir können dann gleich irgendwann
hinten erwischen können jetzt leider
nicht regen ok 120 blöcke glück gehabt
ich hatte irgendwie das gefühl ist eine
hinter mir steht
glück gehabt na ja jetzt so eine runde
ein bisschen streit wer kennt die
wahrscheinlich selbst teilweise hat man
so runden immer so kurz vorm abkratzen
ist das sehr schön scharf muss direkt
also kurz vorm abkratzen ist und die
ganze denkbar ich brauch noch wut und
drei herzen
aber das heißt gar nichts solche runden
kann man auch gerne mal gewinnen
wenn das glück mit einem ist oder das
gilt je nachdem auf dem moment wo wir so
richtig
richtig schön erschöpft sind und auch
ein bisschen zeigen können bisschen
besser zeigen können was er drauf hat
bis jetzt ist es schon ganz gut deutlich
geworden was ihr so kann aber man kann
einfach noch krassere sachen machen
damit immer optimistisch dass das recht
kommen wird so überlässt der entfernt
108 blöcke das heißt wir können jetzt
ein bisschen die zeit nehmen und dann
gleich voll starten
kaum kommt reisen oder gold heißt
weitere rüstungsteile kräften scheidet
aus aber wir können einfach mal checken
jetzt 40 blöcke davon ist der nächste
gegner den hormons jetzt habt ihr
gesehen der zielsatz wieder angeschaltet
und dann macht man einfach extrem viel
schaden macht +2 schaden bei einem
eisenstädter heißt es hat bei dem ihr
sechs grund schaden +125 scharfes +2 es
heißt es macht 925 schadens punkte das
ist extrem viel
das ist wirklich extrem viel und wo ich
sehe gerade wir haben ein bisschen
reisen bekommen das nicht ich sehr gerne
machen uns erstmal gut wie immer muss
man muss ja in einer ganz immer so ein
bisschen mitdenken was das eigene kind
schon mitbringen damit man nicht unnötig
kräfte
aber das haben jetzt endlich gut
hinbekommen habe ich gefühl so jetzt
geben auf den gegner drauf und schau mal
was der zielsicher an dieser und noch so
reißen kann
alles in allem bisher leute kann ich
sagen es ist ein sehr sehr geiles kit
ziemlich cool weil es echt extrem
vielseitig ist also man hat nicht nur
ein effekt denn damit ist es erledigt
man hat extrem viele möglichkeiten und
gmx dabei wir können die von hinten
schnell von hinten
jetzt geht's ab zack zack zack zack
direkt zum sofa modus wieder
angeschaltet und dann machen wir +2
schaden oder hat er keine chance
das ist einfach so sagt die fläschchen
nehmen wir
falls ihr euch fragt wieso ich immer ein
fläschchen und eine leiste lasse das
mache ich damit
falls man inventar fall ist ich nicht
mehr machen muss
wir sind ein bisschen leid ich glaube
wir laufen erst mal und trainer gleich
um und greifen an
oder so ist es und es nur laufen etwas
mehr laufen
jetzt müssen wir laufen und ist live
gehen jetzt in diesem modus okay zur
attacke zielte attacke attacke und bond
oder knapp leute knapp so kann es gehen
ja wie gesagt man kriegt auch extrem
viel schaden
wir nehmen jetzt schon acht minuten auf
ich würde einfach sagen wir gehen von
noch in kurzen runde rein machen einfach
schnell uncut hier
wie wäre es denn mit forrest dann wird
es halt ein bisschen länger folglich
hofft damit connector und schaut die bis
zum ende denn ihr wisst das macht
youtuber glücklich wenn ihr folgen bis
zum ende geschaut werden ist übrigens
wirklich so also wenn ihr euren
lieblings youtuber was gutes tun wollt
dann kommt weniger jetzt innerhalb
youtube weniger darauf an wie viele
kommentare man kippen felix mantik und
mehr darauf wie lange das video geschaut
wird das heißt wenn ihr eure linke
unterstützen wollt dann schreibt auf
jeden fall auch kommentare und laster
aber vor allen dingen die videos zu ende
weil dann werden die besser gelenkt und
pipapo und cpm wendet sich an alle die
auch nicht wissen was das heißt auf
jeden fall ist das ziemlich cool
und es geht weiter die es die us-teams
und eisen und gold gold hat für gott hat
mir gereicht aber wir haben die dias das
ist ziemlich gut da kann man es ein
schönes schwert machen wir weiter alles
klar
gucken kann man auch hier noch eine
kiste ist die wir mitnehmen können
wahrscheinlich davon zu sein ich auf
diese insel da hier vielleicht ist da
oben einen baum sie optisch noch im baum
täuschung so bis hin zu haben wir zwar
auf die atemberaubend nein nein ich
hasse das wenn es schwer nicht auf der
eins ist dann schlage ich einfach mal
mit dem kompass oder demjenigen deshalb
gerade auf der eins liegt so der gegner
scheint sich inszenieren ich hoffe er
macht jetzt keine scheiße
manchmal machen die leute ist ja so dass
sie einem die grafik table abbauen oder
sich dazwischen stellen oder in holz
abbauen will und das ungefähr
allerletzte also da kriege ich immer
einen mords hast bei sowas
ich hoffe es macht er nicht sieht nicht
so aus
sieht eher so aus entwickelt ein
bisschen chillen und es sind noch was
ich wollte sagen es sind ein paar
sekunden aber sind nicht da und da haben
wir in armin exakt okay es down und wir
haben unseren ersten kill
wir haben jetzt schon von hinten
erwischt manche würden sagen dass micky
assassin mäßig vielleicht open jetzt hat
es gesehen jetzt hab ich gesehen
der adac super modus schaltet sich an
das heißt er hat weniger als 50 leben
weniger als 50 prozent seiner leben und
wir gehen es einfach mal drauf und
gucken was passiert hoffentlich nicht zu
gute kommt man hoffentlich nicht
zugewandt und da ist ein loch im boden
die gemeine falle ganz gemeine falle so
jetzt sehen wir aber der modus ist
wieder aus das heißt der gegner den
wieder vornamen der mehr als 50 prozent
erleben und wissen was der da versucht
der ist da im wasser stand
jetzt ist es wieder weg war grad kurz
wieder da okay der gegner hat auch mehr
ihr könnt immer dann wenn ihr kombiniert
zu den kompass anguckt und dann seht ok
weniger als 50 blogger abstand bis zum
nächsten gegner
und dann wiederum merkt okay der modus
ist nicht an der zu super modus dann
wisst ihr der gegner mehr als 50 prozent
seiner leben ist ziemlich cool
eigentlich ja sehr gute komischen von
hitler vision ok alles klar
den nehmen wir mit hatte der zufälligen
bogen
er muss einen bogen haben oder kollegen
keinen bogen
auf jeden fall hier eine schöne lieder
ressorts wie kann man sich mal anziehen
besser als gar nichts ich dass wir hier
quasi nackt durch diese winter lang
laufende friedman sich ja einen ab wenn
auch genug eisen aber ich bin da nicht
so ein eisen stimmung oder doch wir
können noch schnell eine art machen und
almut vielleicht und zwar so dass kleine
kinder anziehen und dann geht's weiter
hier auf den nächsten typen 50 blöcke
abstand ihr seht wiederum ziel so
vermutet schaltet sich nicht an das
heißt er hat noch mehr als die hälfte
seiner leben die wollen wir jetzt aber
abnehmen
er will ist aber nicht schauen wir
substantiven bogen känguru mit bogen ist
natürlich immer ein bisschen anstrengend
vor allem wenn es denn so auf den bäumen
dieser modus an ziel suchmodus andere
jetzt er haut ab haut ab
känguru halten da kann man nichts machen
aber wir wissen heute eher weniger als
die hälfte seiner leben und wir haben
speed 3 das heißt wir können eigentlich
ganz gut hinterher kommen wenn wir jetzt
hier
aber gehen kein großer mal so ein ball
warum reichen territorium doch nicht so
viele chancen
ich sehe wie viel leben was könnt ihr
euch unter hier sehe dass darunter
runter runter das immer noch weniger als
die hälfte
momentan haben jetzt geändert erle
der hat aber noch mehr als die hälfte
und das machen die jetzt mit ihrer
mutter war sehr gut aber ich lasse mich
schnell zack da habt ihr es gesehen wir
haben jetzt wieder ein ziel suchmodus
schön die chance geben können
und wenn ihr im zielraum modus die jetzt
verteilt und keine kassiert dann ist
eigentlich ziemlich safe dass ihr die
sache für euch entscheidet da kommt
jetzt keiner doch das war noch nicht
wir können vielleicht herumschleichen
euro faktor war da offenbar schade
naja gut gespielt heute also hab ich
jetzt hoffentlich genug über das paket
erzählt wir haben jetzt damit keine
runde gewonnen obwohl es wirklich ein
gutes kind ist das könnt ihr mir glauben
spielt am besten selbst mal an schreibt
mir die kommentare welche gerne
vorgestellt haben wollt und ansonsten
wie gesagt lassen like da und dann sehen
wir ein bisschen wieder wieder drei
macht's gut und